how's it going everybody welcome back to
the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and yesterday at cinemacon Sony during
their panel showed the first teaser
trailer or Craven the hunter giving the
first look of Aaron Taylor-Johnson as
Craven himself they also showed us who
the villain of the movie is going to be
or at least one of the villains I think
there is a secret villain out there that
of course I'll go over in this video but
they showed us Rhino or at least a tease
of rhino but most importantly for Sony
they have finally decided to just go for
it this movie is confirmed to be rated R
which I really wish they decided to do
for the Venom movies like seriously we
got a Carnage movie that was PG-13 a
movie about a super messed up serial
killer and the Carnage symbiote who
kills and kills and kills they gave us
that at PG-13 now apparently according
to them they wanted to keep it PG-13 so
Spider-Man could eventually appear and
hopefully that is what is going to
happen for Venom 3 but it does seem and
is pretty much confirmed that Sony is
committing to getting all of these
Spider-Man Side characters together on
screen for a pretty big event eventually
which I'm hoping is a true Sinister 6
movie but we'll talk about Spider-Man
and his connection to all of this later
on in the video we'll start by breaking
down the footage that we saw and of
course if you're a huge Marvel fan be
sure to subscribe to the channel we talk
about it daily and be sure to leave a
comment down below as well it enters you
in our giveaway which we'll talk about
at the end of the video so disclaimer
here I'm a little confused at what was
shown first some Outlets that were there
say that it starts with a rural
Countryside where there's a handful of
apparent mercenaries however according
to Eric Davis over at Fandango he said
that the footage started by seeing
Craven biting a dude's nose off
regardless of how it started both of
these scenes are in the movie so we'll
just break it down we'll talk about the
mercenary scene first though so this
scene takes place in a rural Countryside
where a handful of mercenaries and Poets
teachers are confronted and hacked and
slashed to death by Craven and the
reports from discussing films say that
it is super bloody lots of blood lots of
Gore in this scene basically the movie
like I said is going full out they are
earning their rated R rating this isn't
going to be a typical watered-down Sony
Marvel movie they're going full out and
there's other examples of how gory it's
going to be in bloody it's going to be
later on and really what this scene is
showing us is that Craven the hunter or
Sergey cravenov he is the ultimate
Hunter and in the comics he is a big
game hunter now I'm not sure how they're
going to make him in the Sony Marvel
Universe because after all this is going
to be an origin story for Craven but in
the comics he kind of has his own code
that he sticks to he doesn't like the
use of guns or bows or arrows he does
use blow darts but he prefers to take
down these large dangerous animals just
with his bare hands or knives but his
biggest hunt the ultimate goal for him
is to hunt down and capture in defeat
Spider-Man that's pretty much his
biggest thing in the comics but what is
really interesting about Craven in this
Sony spider-verse film is that Aaron
Taylor Johnson who is playing Craven
described the character as being a
conservationist and protector of the
natural world so I'm kind of wondering
if perhaps Craven the hunter in the Sony
spider-verse does not actually kill
animals since he's a conservationist
that means he wants to preserve wildlife
in the environment so in this scene
where there's poachers and he's killing
them and gutting them to death perhaps
that's his way of kind of saving the
animals maybe his hunt and this movie is
people which would make Spider-Man seem
really really appealing to him because
he's a man but he has the powers and the
abilities of a spider It also says that
the poachers do have animal carcasses so
this is probably why he kills them
because they were killing animals and
the footage describes Craven the hunter
killing them very animalistic like as in
Craven is kind of like an animal himself
when he attacks he uses weapons his
hands on even his own teeth as he bites
a piece of a poacher's face off his nose
and spits out the blood and some have
described the scene stating that he
bites the dude's nose off and spits it
into the camera and throughout the
trailer when he attacks people we see
him use everything from giant Spears to
fully sized bear traps to decapitate and
chop up people into pieces so yeah
they're going full out with the rated R
with the gore and apparently there's a
lot of f-bombs in the teaser as well so
that's one scene then we move on to
narration from Russell Crowe who is
confirmed to be playing the father of
Craven we hear him narrate a little bit
stating what you are and what you'll be
basically noting that he and his son are
both predators and he raised his son in
a very Predator versus prey philosophy
and way and according to Brandon Davis
from comicbook.com Craven is going to
vow to be nothing like his father which
is why I believe his father could be the
true main villain of the film we know
that rhino is going to be a primary
villain of the film but I'm also
wondering if perhaps Craven's father is
behind Rhino we'll get to that in just a
bit but perhaps with his father it's
sort of like a well I raised you one way
and you are not that way so now I'm
basically gonna have to teach you a
lesson so I'm gonna make this rhino
person and you're gonna have to take him
down or I'm gonna have to kill you
myself if Rhino doesn't Now we move into
the City and we see Craven be told that
he is just another man hitting for a
trophy and this kind of explains that
this is indeed An Origin story he is not
the well-known world famous Craven the
hunter yet which is what he wants to be
so given us a hint that this is the
origin for Craven here then we go into a
final scene where Craven is seen sitting
in an office chair and when a person
walks in he throws a spear at the person
the spear goes right through the person
Craven kills them gets his Target and
again this entire teaser all of the
action is described as very gory and
brutal now the last scene is a really
big kind of tease of I know we see a man
inject himself with a serum we then see
his arm start to transform and he says
don't you want to know why they call me
rhino we basically see his arm transform
into the arm of a rhinoceros hinting
that the rest of his body is about to
transform as well so Sony has really
taken a different approach with Rhino
here than they did with the Amazing
Spider-Man in The Amazing Spider-Man 2
Rhino was mechanical whereas in this
film Craven the hunter it's going to be
caused by an injection and it's
basically going to be just a mutation
and the trailer ends with the tagline
nothing survives the hunt so overall
this movie actually sounds like it's
going to be pretty promising since
morbius Sony seems to have a better
handle of the Sony spiderverse that they
are trying to set up and Madame Webb is
an upcoming movie that is supposed to
really set up everything and Sony's
apparently going to be doubling down on
having all of the villains of Spider-Man
eventually come together and this is
interesting because Craven the hunter is
one of the founding members of the
Sinister Six as I mentioned before
Spider-Man is a big Foe for Craven he is
pretty much the Ultimate Prize for
Craven and he really pisses Craven off
because he's never been able to defeat
him so when doc Ott comes to him saying
hey we still Aunt May and we have this
plan to take on Spider-Man you win he
says yes and he's one of the founding
members of the Sinister Six now as far
as what Sony plans to do with vulture
and morbius that's kind of a gray area
right now but keep in mind that Craven
is actually the half brother of
chameleon so perhaps chameleon could be
involved with this Sinister Six project
as well when they eventually go up
against Spider-Man now as far as who our
Spider-Man is going to be we don't
exactly know yet Tom Hardy has teased
heavily that Spider-Man is going to be
in venom 3 and he's already told us that
if he's going for the gold medal in the
Olympics Spider-Man vs Venom that's the
gold medal that's what he's going for so
right now we have every reason to
believe that Venom 3 is going to have
Spider-Man in it so this will more than
likely be when we get introduced to the
new spider man of the Sony spider-verse
but also keep in mind it is a
spider-verse there are probably going to
be multiple different versions of
Spider-Man but I'm very hopeful for a
very good Sinister Six movie since
Craven the hunter so far is rated R very
gory lots of f-bombs apparently they're
really going for it so I hope they
really go for it with their spider-verse
with all of these villains with the
Sinister Six stop watering it down like
the Venom movies nothing against them I
like them but they should have been
rated R and hopefully after all this we
get a really good spider-verse but hey
let me know your thoughts about all of
this in the comments down below what do
you think don't forget to like the video
and subscribe and leave a comment on the
video that interests you for a giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items and some
DC items as well the winner gets to pick
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month you can also follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof